we shouldn't have done a video we should
just put this all in the comment box
hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
then it's John over here you guys have
been in three videos now say your names
late to the party is here with us today
a great reaction channel that also
provides great commentary I absolutely
mean it so please go check these guys
out and deep cut movie trivia knowledge
oh yeah way better than us on the Schmo
down that's for sure I still want the
reaction faction my friend we need to
form our faction is is really solid so
[Laughter]
any actors you will definitely ruin
upcoming films are you guys ready to see
if we agree I think we are
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the situation doesn't have any business
hellraiser revelations by constant
Stefan Smith Connors at the Senate and
that failed miserably Taylor might look
the part when in full makeup but nobody
wants to see a Hellraiser movie with
somebody else in the role especially
extremely wicked but nothing but
qualifies in to play the deeply
disturbed murderer although it will be
funny to think of all the tween faces
display horror when Zach attack stuffed
bonking corpses okay James Corden works
well enough in small doses half-hour
sitcom episodes talk shows and the
occasional bit part
but he wasn't nothing against my
childhood I get it don't continue
there's just my opinion why I'm
genuinely worried about the sequel Chris
Branson bright stars are good actors in
their own right but their characters of
Owen include just some boring trite
dialogue [ __ ] that just spew cliche
terminators likely to work with Arnie
now don't kick my own ass sequel might
be able to use ever mean he could play
an aging t800 again I did enjoy my size
well though Arnie was pretty
unconvincing as a geriatric killing
machine in the last movie having him in
a terminator movie and in a non
terminator role will be too distracting
just right sophie turner x-men Dark
Phoenix I love being a Rhodes and I love
x-men bussines sophie turner churn out a
lifeless performance as Jean Grey was
painful to call her wooden would be an
insult to the raw material itself most
of it was down to a lack of confidence
in her American accent which she just
kept on forgetting to maintain and
elevate she had to be the focus of the
Dark Phoenix saga it's only going to
highlight these issues she's a capable
actor but she's one that's still
learning Game of Thrones is a good
nesting ground for her as we've seen a
move from weak to strong in more ways
than one
however jumping from a dialogue based
show to an action film is proving to be
a struggle that she just simply isn't
rising to at present and that's all
negative
oh so negative list oh look at you well
drop me a comment down below letting me
know which other actors you reckon might
ruin upcoming films and then why not
swing by what cops rock on for more news
novels like this
today as well as typing Jules you've
been all soon I'll speak to you soon to
the end to the video aren't you a star
subscribe of course ok well this might
be the first list from what culture
where I don't fully agree with what
they're saying quite a few because it
kind of issued the idea that people
could try something different
yeah yeah most of the time when I hear
their listen like this one or two I
disagree with this one I was like I
could kind of question a lot of what
they actually put down let's go through
it a little bit they make a good point
about Rihanna possibly not really
shining so strong because she's up
against a lot of there's other actresses
in those like Sarah Paulsen's in there
raised a fantastic actress as well I
didn't see Rihanna's big screen roles I
heard she was pretty good in Bates Motel
we saw her and valerian and there's no
reason for her character but I feel like
if there was anybody else in that
character it would still kind of feel
the same yeah and also it's an oceans
movie and at the end of the tapes that
this is it's an oceans movie and
everybody has to be a dynamite actor yes
in the oceans movie you've got George
Clooney Brad Pitt and Matt Damon and no
one gives a powerful performance in that
movie like Bernie Mac from you know TV
yeah comedy it's not a movie that I
think requires high-caliber strong
acting it's usually these oceans movies
are it's cool to just see a giant cast
assemble and what I would like them to
do more I don't imagine Rihanna will
also be one of the main people we focus
on of course it seems like gonna be like
Sandra Bullock and Cate Blanchet as the
main faces well we'll pay most attention
to and that's the thing is you take
veteran actors there and you put them
with newer actors and things could
happen in a good way you get a lot of
collaboration just in terms of those
that have been doing it forever and
those that have just started I mean if
you get something good sometimes and
that could be a situation where she
shines bright like a diamond
in this story feel like if she were to
give the kind of importance that Alicia
Keys smokin aces if she gives that kind
of saying cuz I have that feeling that
maybe she'll be that kind of character
right I'm banking on it I think that
maybe she'll have that thinking she's a
pretty guy voice over as well at home
that's the thing is home not our
demographic but it was pretty successful
and she is the main character it did
pretty well I know it was popular I
should also be taking some acting
lessons yeah to brush up for a bigger
every for a huge movie like this with
this cast I'm not going to watch this
movie be like this hall T Taylor is the
new pinhead okay I'm not that familiar
with that I know John's really familiar
with the Hellraiser franchise were you
guys sure all right very well with what
he was talking about bringing somebody
else to that character and they even
showed it a little bit with Nightmare on
Elm Street when they reboot it Jackie
Earle Haley and it was a robber teen
yeah wasn't Robert Englund and you can
totally tell you're like it's not
Freddie's different it just didn't work
with me you have to realize though a lot
of it does come down to direction as
well think about the new penny wise will
love the new penny wise worse
yeah but Tim Curry's Pennywise was
monumental the epic and the idea of
getting a different type of penny wise
seemed very off-putting at first right
but then if you have a great director
guiding you you could bring out a
fantastic performance it's like Jackie
Earle Haley in nightmare house region
he's a fantastic actor and he could have
made that role yeah I still believe he
could have now I don't think they're
gonna give as much TLC to Hellraiser
reboot as they did for it reboot and the
other part - that makes it troublesome
is the main actor who played Hellraiser
is still around right there's Tim Curry
as a condition where he can't do that
anymore when you have the actor still
around it's like why not still use yeah
it seems like I don't know exactly for
sure but it seems like Doug Bradley's
game they brought that up as the whole
like making movies to keep the rights
and stuff and think about how razors is
like there are I get their points like
there are so many movies now you know
the shape of Doug Bradley's head
so after a certain point it's always
gonna be a little bit distracting but I
think they could also do a lot to
improve production values of that
franchise because it does seem kind of
apparent that what dimensions willing to
invest is the amount that keeps them the
right and right that makes a great
Hellraiser movie yeah it seems like
they're doing what they can with what
they have zac efron as Ted Bundy this is
a conflicting casting choice because Zac
Efron is an actor who has grown on me a
lot primarily because of comedies right
there's something that's to be said
about when an actor grows as an actor in
comedies because I think of like
Channing Tatum I didn't really like his
acting he does 21 Jump Street he does
great in comedy and then suddenly he's
even better in dramas like where did
that come from
so for all I know Zac Efron might be
even better now as a dramatic actor
strictly because of his comfort in front
of the camera now and the fact that he's
willing to do more Gary risky things and
also in terms of looks and appeal Ted
Bundy he was really popular for the fact
that he was very charming he was
good-looking he was it was it was he
didn't fit that typical profile because
you're like he seems like an actual
charismatic appealing dude who can
actually win over a jury and I feel
exactly everyone has that ability to do
that the problem comes is will we be
able to see past Zac Efron the way how
we did with like Charlize Theron with
monster just go it's this is just Ted
Bundy and Michael Fassbender and jobs is
very different than watching Ashton
Kutcher play Steve Jobs kind of expand
his acting chops it also like we said
before it comes down to direction as
well yeah if you have a cast and crew it
will work and I think that Zac Efron
again it will probably be a problem
because I hope that I don't I don't want
to see Zac Efron be Zac Efron I don't
want him that's probably the issue that
I will have my best friends for yeah we
need him to not be Zac Efron be like oh
I'm just watching Zac Efron playing dead
but instead if I'm watching Ted Bundy
yeah it's a gamble more than it is like
oh what were you thinking I'm like part
of the charm is that it's parallel like
Zac Efron is super handsome and charming
just like Ted Bundy was like you
right and I think it'll come down to you
know does he have that sort of Tom Hardy
level of like being able to just change
your expressions and your mannerisms a
bit the stakes here for me are that it's
hard to make a good serial killer biopic
not many good ones exist and like my
friend Dahmer just came out and that's
and that guy was a Disney accident alley
and that makes me think about this
because that movie got pretty good
receptions which is better than a lot of
the serial killer biopics
oh yeah so it'll come down to the
quality of the movie as well as his
performance James Corden as Peter Rabbit
I don't really get why I was really
biased that's sort of really read off to
me as they just don't really like James
Corden in general I like James Corden
I've seen him do like bits here and
there I don't think I've seen him like
lead a full like fictional thing the
movie he did with the Keira Knightley
and Mark Ruffalo I like to know just
legit yeah and I don't think he'd be
like that annoying or over the top for a
voice-over role I seems like something I
haven't really like totally fine yeah
and that's the thing is they did
Paddington and Paddington came out and
it was something that was so charming
that everybody loved it whether it was a
kids in the adult if they approach it
that same style where he's not
over-the-top but he is a little bit more
I mean family friendly in terms of just
someone you would welcome this little
rabbit into at home I mean they will
kill it they are capable to the fact
where but I can also understand because
it's something that he grew up with
right now he loves and you have some
it's like it's like one of those where
you have somebody pictured in your mind
and then when it actually you see it on
screen or see it and like in a big
theatre and it's not that person or it's
not that voice that you heard you kind
of get disappointed a little bit I just
discovered this movie existed and I grew
up with Peter Rabbit too and there's
nothing about James Corden to me that
suggests that he can't do something
that's sweet and endearing and and on
pitch because he's already a sweet
seeming affable guy yeah I can't I don't
have any trouble seeing him doing this
move
I'm more concerned about what the movie
is yeah this sort of live-action CG
thing is is more what I would be worried
about than the casting of James yeah
yeah Taron Egerton as Robin Hood that's
another one where I'm like I can totally
see Taron Egerton pulling this off
absolutely if you see Kingsman granted
yes they're right in the sense that the
films are like what was Eddie the Eagle
and Kingsman a much lighter tone than
something that they're talking this new
Robin Hood film to be like the thing
though is is he's very believable Incans
and in Eddie the Eagle and they're very
different carriage very different
mannerisms and voices they're super
super different and the fact that he can
pull that off even if it's a lighter
tone film makes me just automatically
feel like do that because he hasn't done
something gritty necessarily doesn't
mean you wouldn't be able to do it when
I feel like this might even be less
challenging possibly a step down for him
even namely that he needs to do we have
a million Robin Hood's we have and King
Arthur's yeah you know there's all these
characters that we keep going back to so
if they did approach it in a different
way I'm just hoping it does not fall
into the same category as those other
movies where it's like oh now here's
another Robbie of it again kind of like
what John was saying about Peter Rabbit
is how I feel like this I'm like I'm Way
less concerned about Taron Egerton than
I am more concerned about how is this
movie gonna know I could totally see
turn being Robin Hood he has like that
very suave like way of being Robin Hood
I can totally see him go a different
direction like you said before Craig
about how he is two different characters
in these two different movies and he
plays them so well in both scenes that
you don't see eggsy Eddie the Eagle you
see his character an eagle and eggsy Sam
casting him as Robin Hood I feel like
they know what they're doing he must
have done something to prove to them
that like okay you're the Robin Hood
though that we envisioned to be in this
part yeah Kingsman proof she's got the
body build and he can fight right she
seems perfectly doesn't parkour doesn't
he actually I think he does part cos
yeah Kingsman there's that
like what we really does yeah the only
thing that bugs me about his casting and
this because I'm with you guys I'm sort
of like I don't know if we need another
gritty King a gritty Robin or I feel
like we did that with Russell Crowe and
that didn't work so great either this
formula it may be a little played out
but my only concern about casting Taron
Egerton is that I just wish he would
have done this role later because we're
getting to know him as an actor and he's
doing Kingsman and he's doing any of the
eagle and stuff like that I feel like a
few more movies down the line he as
Taron Egerton is established it's not
reliant on the Kingsmen or any other
thing then I can see him as Robin Hood
right now I'd be a little distracted
trying to lose him into that character
that's totally possible - because it
kind of gives me that feel as well like
with Daisy Ridley her being a Star Wars
they're kind of pulling her to these
other roles that I'm not sure that
she'll fit in because they're just
putting her cousins yeah yeah I feel
like maybe - they're pulling Taryn
because he did so well in Kingsman and
he's very likable with the audience
right now well we have to get somebody
that will probably bring people to the
theater because Taryn oh he was in that
Kingston movie and you think the word
associate cuz they borrow the King
Arthur stuff yeah so you can like
associate your way to be like okay yeah
pretty funny Chris Pratt and Bryce
Dallas Howard owned like those
characters how do you guys feel that
Jurassic world it might have been
because of when we went to the theater
everyone was super pumped is so excited
that it was like yeah this movie but
then I haven't watched it since the only
stuff which really gets right is the the
cool dinosaur stuff the dinosaur is in
the moments those moments that hit for
the first time with that audience it was
great not one of them was Bryce Dallas
Howard and very few redeeming right
weight to the cast yeah I totally agree
with him with them being these just like
going banter back and forth because I
remember like watching them and I was
like I don't really care like let's just
get to the good part yeah like if they
did a sequel and they said they're not
returning I could care less like you
should have gone that way yeah feels
like okay we moved on the park is
dismantled if anything bring Chris Pratt
back let's give him a whole new I'm
Gannett of actors to play with
especially Jeff Goldblum which we know
is coming back I don't need them to come
back I don't know if it'll ruin it if
they figure out a clever way and the
writing yeah to be able to push it
forward but again if they writing
they're writing they're just going it's
the dinosaurs it's action scenes
it's the popcorn and it's the billions
of dollars that comes with no movie ever
since the first Jurassic Park has been
able to nail down interesting human
characters in this Jurassic Park
franchise since the first one it feels
like they've all gone and distracted
with Dinosaurs every day which is so
important integral what made the first
one so great was beyond going yeah you
care about the characters the characters
are just great in the first one first
Jurassic Park the characters actually
have a story right you know and in
Jurassic world and a lot of the sequels
it feels like how do we get people in
the dinosaur I wanted to do a video
about the new Terminator movie because
we did one video on it where I was
pretty anti like I'm not excited for
this it sounds stupid there's often
times when they hear the quotes from
James Cameron and Tim Miller talking
about this new Terminator they just give
you like quotes in an article I watched
the entire interview they did I think
it's from variety or Hollywood Reporter
and it was like a 45-minute interview
which really I started talking about
John about I actually am very excited
for it and I trust them now there's so
much to the entirety of the interview
where you see they've factored in
everything they've factored in every
little detail and they secretly been
working on this hardcore for many many
months now and they've hinted out what
they want Armel to possibly be that they
probably want to be a terminator but
some human version I don't think it
would ruin the feel like to say these
actors will ruin the movie is kind of
ridiculous to me because it also doesn't
sound like that are gonna be the main
yeah there's not Jai Courtney if you say
Zach that front sucks as Ted Bundy is
that will ruin
yes but if Arnold sucks then Terminator
they summer they got this whole much
bigger thing going on than just Arnold
being in it then I don't think it could
ruin the entire film it's kind of like
their Forte in the Terminator movies
whether it's after - of course where
they're like we're gonna just get some
cookie cutter actor and throw it in
there and the two that are like the top
cookie cutter actors are Sam Worthington
and Jai Courtney and both of them were
in terminator yeah if they can at least
put more quality actors with Arnold
whether he's a human whether he ends up
being a terminator yeah like that will
end up propelling these movies into a
whole new you know resurgence of the
franchise was resurgence anyway this is
gonna come down to James Cameron and Tim
Miller and and I have some faith kind of
because of Tim Miller because of like
you know sticking to his guns leaving
Deadpool for creative differences and he
seems gung-ho about this and I mostly
trust James Cameron's judgment I feel
like he would still be sharp so yeah
aren't Arnold isn't gonna break this
movie it needs to be a good like in this
landscape where we keep revitalizing the
classics from before that we love but
can't figure out how to have an issue at
this point labeled just needs to be in
it I just see cornered Arnold to return
back regarding compromise and he can be
an old teacher two dealers that live
down the street all the way okay
so Peter and x-men dark already well
yeah I mean Apocalypse itself no one
none of the new cast members were really
that great no it just seemed like the
one Bryan Singer seemed less passionate
about to begin
he has got these young act like young
Cyclops was in cool young gene first off
the x-men franchise has not gone in Jean
Grey down at all honey but not even when
they had rocky Johnson yeah Oh neato
not even her it was great it's kind of
just a disappointment they've been doing
with the Jean Grey character now for
this one it's that are calling this
x-men Dark Phoenix the Simon Kinberg he
he worked on the stripper x-men The Last
Stand I feel like he's gonna put a lot
of attention to detail because this is
first time he's directing an x-men movie
first direction or movies directing this
is his chance to do right what he did
what everything went wrong with the Dark
Phoenix story I imagined that this time
around that he's gonna do his best to
make sure Jean great kicks acid the film
x-men 2 it's like yeah she is Dark
Phoenix so it's very important that she
does a great job same time though Tex
man there's a huge in samba love
character this is one of those cases
where I feel like you can walk out
specifically pinpointing if sophie
turner does a good job or not like it
might be one of the things you talk
about same time though i don't think she
could ruin the entirety of the film
because there's already such a huge cast
that everyone's gonna no one's gonna
really want a cg gray you can totally
tell though too from when she started
among camera sons to now like her acting
abilities really yeah really evolved and
i didn't care for her character in game
of thrones because of the way that she
portrayed and granted she was my you
care but now I'm just like oh I'm really
excited when rush she's on screen and
the way that she plays her character
yeah I feel like she can bring a lot to
the Jean Grey and the Dirk yes and
that's the thing is you're pretty much
we can really only fairly judge this
based off of what we saw in Apocalypse
like that is the one thing that in terms
of her character and what you played so
yeah you can't really differentiate you
know what happens when you do have
somebody that is well far more invested
in what is going on in the Phoenix story
the comic series like one of my favorite
arcs in the comic series was the Phoenix
I mean the Phoenix will rise again the
Phoenix will fall I mean it was
definitely something that I did want to
see happen correctly when it came to
x-men the lost and and when they took
out Jean Grey and next to like I was
hoping for it and yeah it was just a way
so yes putting a little more time and
energy let's focus on the Dark Phoenix
and let's go
there and hopefully I don't think sophie
Turner will end up screwing the pooch on
it I mean she did leave an impression on
me by not leaving an impression on me as
Jean Grey I didn't really find anything
one way or the other about her
performance and the thing is I have not
personally had a high success rate
seeing Game of Thrones actors in movies
like Emilia Clarke couldn't carry
terminator Nikolaj coster-waldau is fine
in the movies I've seen him in but he
doesn't seem to grab I'm gonna say they
they all can't do it I'm just saying
there is a thing right now where we are
very much like look we got a game of
Thrones actor to lead this not enticing
me anymore the way it used to this is
called Dark Phoenix right so I feel like
the onus is on her to really show up and
knock it out of the park and yeah Game
of Thrones I feel like she can but I am
NOT a hundred percent confident in it
yet I don't feel like a lot of people
really care for her a salsa but then she
grew and not just in terms of the
character in the writing but also as a
performer she's grown I'm optimistic in
the same way how she steps are flooded
into this much bigger territory Fox
movie comic wood and and then so she
gets her feet wet with that and now
should you be more comfortable coming in
and knowing how to readjust or enhance
certain aspects of her acting abilities
for this specific tale and I feel like
she will take it very serious well yeah
after all the feedback from what can
yeah pocalypse the fallout if you will
of the apocalypse I have faith in her I
have faith I wouldn't sit here be like
she's gonna everything I'm alright well
what culture you got a long-ass descent
and out of us great debate list you put
together here subscribe and walk culture
because they make some great points and
they're wonderful list videos were they
really just say what they want they
stick to their guns on what they're
saying what I like them is because
there's other list videos where I warm
like you're just clearly trying to
satisfy YouTube commentators yeah but
these guys just stick to their guns each
and every time and that's what I love
these guys so please subscribe to them
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell you can become a
patron object today by joining our
patreon it really does help support the
channel plus to get some awesome reward
tiers as well most importantly
subscriber late to the party LTT they
are also a channel that features
reaction
and they are also wonderful with
commentary they kick ass on the Schmo
down love you guys glad we got a hangout
thank you bringing us we appreciate it
so much and hopefully you guys have a
safe trip back to the Arizona long drive
home you never go back to Arizona we
could never go back there we've got a
long drive but man when you post it on a
howl right when you get there send us
some greetings from Tucson timely
references peeps alive in Tucson
[Music]